お休みいたします サンタニタッサマナンホーティサンターワーチャーチャカンマチャサンマダンニャーヴィムッタッサウパサンタッサターディノーという偈ですね
で この言葉で あの 悟りに達した人の心はどのようなものかと説明するところです
サンタンタッサマナンホーティというのは
心はとても平和に安らかになっている
それからサンターワーチャ
言葉もとても安らかな穏やかな清らかな言葉になっていて
ワーチャーチャカンマチャ行いもそのように大変清らかな行になっているんだ
で なんで考えも言葉も行いも清らかになっているのかというと
サンマダンニャーヴィムッタッサ
それ理由は？理由は言うんですね
サンマダンニャーっていうのは
正しく ありのままに 如実に
よく知って ヴィムッタッサ
解脱に達している その人という
ウパサンタッサ いわゆる安穏の境地に達している
ターディノーっていうのは
揺らぎのない境地に達している
で まあまあ それだけの偈ですからね
まあ別に 難しい意味というのはありません
このサンタサンタっていうのは
この まあインドでも普通に使っている言葉で
この祝福の言葉にも使ってるんですね
インドの場合はね よくシャンティシャンティという祝福の言葉があります
それは祝福がありますようにという意味でありますけど
いわゆる安穏でありますように
安らかで安らかにありますようにという意味で
シャンティという言葉はいまだに
まあ使っている単語なんです
まあだから普通の言語の言葉なんですね
安らかな気分でいたいっていうのは
まあ一応人間の希望でもあります
安らかに穏やかに安穏な気分でいたいと
で 気持ちはありますけどね
そうなりたいと なかなかなれないというのも現実ですね
安らかにはなりたいんだけど
どうもなれなくなっちゃうっていうね
混乱 興奮はしたくはないんだけど
してしまうというのは
まあそれは現実ですね
理想的にはそうなりたくはないという
まあ隔たりが出てくるんですね
現実と理想という間とかね
それで まああまりにも現実すぎて
まあそんな理想や観念があっても
なれるわけじゃないと言って諦める
混乱するのは興奮するのは心乱れるのは
それは当たり前のことではないかと思って諦める道もあります
気持ちは心穏やかでいたいという気持ちがあっても
これはありえないんだと
そういう人々もいるし
まあいろいろ工夫して穏やかな気持ちになろうではないかと
まあいろいろ工夫する人々も２種類がいるのです
仏教はどちらかというと
希望があるならば なんでこれ頑張れないのかっていうね
基本的にはそういう思考パターンなんですね
何か希望があるならば
まあそれはそれでなんで頑張れないのかと
自分の力で希望に達するのだっていうのは
仏教の教えで まあそれはできませんというね
自分の力ではなくて 他人の力で希望を実現できるんだという風に言う世界もあります
人間としては やっぱり誰かがやってくれるならば
その方がありがたいと思うのは普通ですね
ということだから 自分の力で何とかしますという人々はかなり少ないんです
誰かにやってもらいたいと
思っている人間たくさん
誰かにね 自分の幸福 幸福実現党ではないんですけど
あれはのそっとの党ですからね
あの幸福実現してくれる誰かがいるならば
まあその人にすがってしまうというのは
まあだからその人々はものすごい数が多いんですね
自分で何とかしますという人々は少ないんですね
世の中で成功する人と失敗する人の数えをすると
成功 成功している人の方が少ないんですね
失敗している人の方が多いんですね
そこで統計的に考えると
自分で何とかする人々はなんとかなりますからね
だからその人はまあ自分が成功していると言うし
他人がやってくれると思っている人々にとってはね
ちょっとそこはすごく疑問にはなりますね
本当に他人がそこまでやってくれるのかと
他人の場合はね いろんな人が勝って出ますね
私が人類を救ってあげるぞとかね
私がやってあげるぞ 私がやってあげるぞとかね
もうなんかものすごいこの夏はハエが流行ってる
流行るような感じで 至る所にそういう救済者たちがね
次から次へと出てくるんですね
この人を救ってあげるということは
まぁ仏教はあんまり難しい教えじゃないんだからね
そういうシンプルなことを教えますからね
もうだからそんなに大したことはなくて
一般的なことを言ってますね
まぁこれは無理じゃないかなとね
そう言うんですね 人を助けてあげたり
救ってあげたりすることは無理じゃないかな
どうしたっても人間がみんな一人一人で頑張ってみなきゃダメでしょうと
他人にはどうすることもできないという
なんかすごいみんなの期待をね
外れる 嫌な言葉を言うんですね
仏教は一般的に 聞きたがっているのは
もう汝らを私が救ってあげますという言葉なんですね
私を信仰すれば 私を通りにやるならば
私のこれこれぐらいのもうお布施やらね
尊敬やら もう私を讃嘆して褒めてくれるならばやってあげますよというふうなことですから
そこはだいたい聞きたがる話ですけど
これは無理やというとね
ものすごく聞きたくはないんですね
無理だけではなくて 私が救ってあげるという言葉を言う人が
あの恐ろしい詐欺師か
極限な精神的な病気かっていうね
間ないんです 普通の常識のお母さんにしても
子供に私は何でもやってあげるぞとは言わないんです
子供のことを愛することは全くもう疑いなく
もう確実ですけどね まあ世界ではね
やっぱり人のことは産んだ母親ほどは誰も心配はしませんよ
その人はだから自分にとって世の中にある唯一な自分のことを心配する存在でしょう
言わないんですね あなたのことなら何でもやってあげます
だからどうですかね うちのお母さんがそう言わないし
隣の開祖様がそう言っているし
でっかいビルを作って隠れている開祖様がね
ギリシア建築の真似で
日本にも合わない建物をね
作ったりして隠れているんです
その人は作ってくれ 何でもやってくれると
これどう理解すればいいんですかね
うちのお母さんは自分のことをすごい嫌っていると
顔は見たことはない 見ることもできんというね
写真見てもオカマみたいな化粧した顔で
あの 一度見たらもうやっぱり卵子だったらよかったなとかね
思うぐらいはすごい美男で
[笑い]だからその人は自分のことを本当に心配しているのか
自分を生んだお母さんがね
鬼かと まあ考えた方がいいんですけど
どう考える能力もないね
やっぱり開祖様の方が正しいと思っちゃうでしょうね
だからそこを完全に詐欺か
完璧に精神的にイカれているかというね
どちらかなんですね お釈迦様は論理的には救ってあげることはできませんと
で 母親の気持ちは何なのかというと
子供はしっかり自分で何でもできるようになってほしいという
自分でも何でもできる人間になって
また周りの人々も助けてあげる人間になってほしいって思っちゃうんですね
だから 現代社会の人々の気持ちから見れば
それが間違いで 正しいのはもう助けてあげますという人の話だと思っちゃうんです
当然助けてもらいたくなるのも
もうこの躾が良くない人々なんですね
精神的に独立させてないんです
神におねだりしなさいとかね
あちらにお祈りしなさい
こちらにお祈りしなさいとか
あれやこれやと言って
この精神的な弱さをね
しっかりと定めてくれるんですね
だから 神にお祈りするとすごい気分がいいんじゃないかとかね
まあこの心理学関係の人々も言いますけどね
やっぱりいろいろ問題があると
もう神様でも信仰していれば
もう 神様助けてくださいと言えれば
その人はそれで気持ちが良くなるんだと
だったらね カウンセラーたちはね
まあそこら辺の十字架でもね
まああのあのグロテスクな神の人相でもね
作っておいて そこでお祈りさせればいいんですけどね
だからそういう心理学を学んでいると言っても
何してるかよくわからないんだけど
この弱さを 許可してどうするのかと
であの仏教の中ではね
あの浄土系の思考考えっていうのはね
まあ人間は何もする必要はないんだよね
で 阿弥陀さんがまあ救ってくれると
うん その場合はね まあ世の中でね
いろいろ災難に遭っちゃうと
人間がすごく悩んだりするし
だからまあ宗教家が来てね
悩む必要ないんだと あなたの亡くなった人々は
まあ阿弥陀様に迎えに来て往生してますから
それは喜ぶべきやと という話を聞くと
ああそうですか よかったなと思うんですね
みんな お母さん死んでよかったと
子供が死んでよかったと
どこまでなんかちょっと私には
まあそれは実際に実際経験ある人々に聞かなくちゃいかんですよ
まあね 結構みんないろんな不幸なことに出会うでしょうに
子供は死ぬわ 無病気になるわ
突然若いうちに旦那が死ぬわとか
で 子育てはなかなか大変できなくなっちゃうとか
その場合はもう阿弥陀様が迎えに来たと
それはありがたい話ですね
あの長男が生まれて三ヶ月間
旦那が仕事中何か事故を起こしちゃって死んだと
結構ありがたいんですね
それが 阿弥陀様がね 往生
往生しましたからね そうすると
その若い奥さんがすごく喜ぶべきなんです
よかったよかった うちの旦那もう自分長男生まれて三ヶ月なんですけど
さっさと極楽堂に招かれて
なんて幸せですか 神を信じる連中がもう神に召されましたと言うんだからね
ありがたいことね  それでも終わらなくてね
まあこう 神やら他力を批判する人々に対してはすごい攻撃まで強とするんです
だからね よーく普通人間に考えればね
まあどうしたって普通の普通の人間いるんですかね
世の中に なんかちょっとわからないね
今日メールがありましてね
あの神は本当にいるんだぞという宣伝している本のリストがありましてね
もうもう全部新作のもうできたばっかりなんですね
結構たくさん本でしたけどね
またもうまた来月 今月中
今月末とか また出版しますからとかね
注文して読もうかなとね
思うべきかどうかね で
そういうことで 他力ってありがたいかどうかね
まあめんどくさいんだからね
周りのこと喋るのはね
やっぱり病気なんです
明確に病気なんです だから縋る人も病気なんです
そこわかるでしょうね
最近もそういうテレビのニュースでね
もう男が死んじゃったというニュースがありまして
もう結婚してまた子供が生まれたばっかりなんですね
博打でも大富豪でも叩いてお祭りしましょうよ
だって若いお尻天国のおめざまのところにもう行ったんだからね
だからそういう話聞いて
自分が気持ちが落ち着きましたと
悩みがなくなりましたというと
あれって何ですかね 私は怒鳴りますけどね
だから私はとても悪い人間だと
旦那が死んだ 子供が死んだと泣いてくると
いい加減にしろよと私は言うんですけど
しかし それこそ恐ろしい人で
でもそれはもう神様のところに行かれましたからね
感謝するべきだと言ったら
それが喜んで帰るならば
阿弥陀様感謝感謝とかね
神様感謝感謝 うちの子供は６歳で死にましたとかね
まあ長男が高校高校1年生で死にましたよ
あんたなんて不幸ですかとかね
旦那も借金して家を作ったんだけど
もう家終わり前に死にましたとかね
私もう死にましたではなくて
神様のところに行かれましたと
私はなんて幸せ者かと
子供がなくて借金だけあって主人もなくて
こんな恵みってあるのかい？とかね
そう思うんですかね だから口先で言わなくても落ち着くでしょ
そういう人々は結局は
神の話は阿弥陀の話を聞いちゃう
だから無意識であの理屈を使っているんです
でなきゃ落ち着きないはずでしょう
そういうわけで やっぱりそれはもう明らかに病気なんですね
病気でない人でも他に他にすがろうとすると
見事にもう感染して病気になってしまいます
他は何もやってくれません
それはブッダの立場なんです
仏教のこの自力を説明する場合は
あまり難しい理論は使ってないんです
自分で歩いて自分で座って
自分で喋って 自分でご飯食べて
自分で仕事をして 自分で呼吸をして
神がやってくれると思っているんだよという説明なんです
だから これは哲学者と喧嘩したところで言った言葉ですから
その言葉ではないんです
使っているのはね このアッタカーラ
パラカーラというね アッタカーラというのはもう Self effort ということで
自分で自力ですね パラカーラというのは他人の力によってということで
それは他力ですね だから自力他力にはパーリ語ではアッタカーラ
パラカーラという でも全てはパラカーラであると
他力であるとね それでお釈迦様はニコッと笑ってね
自分で歩いて 自分で座ってね
こちらにね 他力というのを言うんだと
自分でやってやらせているんだというんだからね
すごい立派でしょ 能力は
で ブッダは馬鹿にするんですね
この超越した形而上学的な世界はわからないんだからね
あんたはと だからお釈迦様は随分馬鹿にされてますよ
お釈迦様髪の毛剃ってますからね
このハゲハゲだとわからないの
ハゲハゲのシャムにはわからないんだ
そういうふうに言っている文章はあります
すごい頭がいいことですね
ああいうふうに分かっていることも
お釈迦様から見れば 自分で手
これ自分で上げているんだったよね
しかし すごい頭がいい人は
いえいえ あなた上げているんじゃないんだよ
それは神様が上げさせているんだよと
神が入らなきゃ何もならないんだということで
この他力をすごく説得力ある話にするんです
だから世の中で地球上にいる人間の 90%以上他力を信仰しています
日本の場合 最もパーセントが高いでしょうと思いますね
あまりにも他力他力というね
もう他人の力によって
ハルフィアの洗脳座禅こんでるお坊さんでいてね
読めない人なんですけど
やっぱり悟りっていうことは自分で悟るんじゃないんだと
それは向こう側から悟らせてくれるんだっていう風に
随分真剣に喋るんですね
だから あまりにもややこしい日本語で難しい
喋るのは私にはほとんどわからないんだけど
まあ聞いている人は感動すること
私はもう私に分かったのは
もう誰かが悟らせてくれると思っているんだけど
やっぱりもうこの人は相当アホやと
もう日本では人気あるんだからね
黙っていろよ この場合は
で 麻薬中毒同士で頑張ってください
だからそういう連中はね
やっぱりそういう真面目に考えてからその結果になるんですね
だから真面目に考えてなんですかね
いろんなテキストを読んだり
漢文を読んだり 西洋哲学まで読んだりして
また学位もたくさん持って
大学教授とかやっていて
それから修行に挑戦する
だから相当立派な 大変苦労して頭を使って考えているんですけどね
だからよくわからないんですね
そこはそういう結論に達するもんだなと
でもお釈迦様立場からすれば
あなた今手を挙げたのは神が上げさせたのか
あなたが挙げたのかということで問題は解決ですけど
あれは実験してみたらどうですかね
もう横になる 横になって一生懸命神に祈る
神でもいいし 鬼でもいいし
自分信仰しているものは犬でも猫でも誰でもいいんですけどね
カエルとかね カエルは信仰
ネズミは信仰するは それで狐は信仰するはね
猿をインドは猿を信仰しているは
もう神って結構いるんですよ
だから自分が信仰している神
何でもいいんだから ちょっと実験してみたらどうですかね
もう横になって 神様ご自分の力で私を起こしてくださいと
それはもう神の栄光になることであると
あのジェホワっていうあの悪の神が随分褒めてほしいんですね
犬と同じなんですね 犬もすごく褒めると気分がいいでしょ
と同じなんですね あのイエホワという神が
もう褒めると随分気分がいいんですね
そうすると伝染病でも送ってくれるんです
で 他はプレゼント持ってないんです
で もういいことをしてあげたというケース
記録ないんです 伝染病で殺すとかばっかりやってます
まあどうでもいいんですけど
しかし 自分の栄光になることをやりますということなんですね
栄光というんですか 光栄でしたっけ
だったらやってしたどうですかね
そんな神様にはそんな大げさなことを頼みませんよと
そんな簡単なことで うちの息子にでもできますよと
これぐらいは 私は横になっていると
時々自分がちょっと足が痛くて
もう腰が重くて立てなくなっちゃったら
まあね もう若い息子がいるならばね
私はちょっと立たせてくれと言うでしょうに
そうすると息子がブーブー言いながらでももう起こしてあげるでしょ
だから大したことじゃないんです
それぐらいことをなんで頼んでみないんですかね
立たせてくれと それで十分やと
別に他はもうもうなんて言いますか
宝富士投手は立ってくれとかね
あの息子に世界一美人をね
もう結婚させてくれとそういうの頼みませんよ
給料は会社の給料を倍にしてくれとか
それはいいんですけど
ただ今横になってる私をもう起こしてくださいと
それもうちの息子にもできるし
旦那にもできるんだよと
まあそれぐらいのことでもやっちゃえばよくわかりますね
他力で世界が動いてるんだったらね
実験してみたら だからそういうシンプルな理論でね
まあお釈迦様に見えたら結局自分で全てやってるの
そういうことで このすべて自分でやるということは
仏教は正しい立場であると思っているんですね
アッタカーラ・アバラカーラの場合はアッタカーラという他力で他力ではなくて
自力という 人はそうってます
だから幸福になりたいとかね
あれこれとかね 権力が欲しいとかね
長くしたいとか 人間の希望がある場合は自分で何とかしなさいと仏教は言うんです
それで自分で何とかしなさいと言うと
また別な問題が起きてくるんですね
その人は着々こと客観的に生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
すごい論理的 幸福になりたければ
だって神はやってくれないでしょう
宝くじ一等賞当たってほしいなと思ったら
このバカが宝くじ買うはめになっちゃう自分で
1枚2枚10枚買っても当たらないでしょうにね
じゃあ当たる確率が高いくしていければ
まあ 1万枚とか 100万枚とか買わなくちゃってことになっちゃうんですね
200円の宝くじ  100万枚
やめようと それよりはどうかね
バイトした方がいいとかね
とにかくそういう風に
当然具体的に生きるはめになっちゃうんですね
あの これテレビで聞いた話で
言っても言っても そのために行ったんじゃなくて
別な用事があって あのよく当たる宝くじの売り場があるんですね
はい 場所どこですか？え？有楽町
有楽町のはうるさいこと
だからそこであれほど人を集めて宝くじ買うでしょう
結構合理的な人間ですね
すごい理性的で さすが世界経済大国のこの第3のアジア人と違いますね
頭が良くて だって私はどこまで侮辱されたことかというとね
アジア人がね 迷信がありすぎちゃって
あれやこれやとかね 我々現代人はそうではありませんと
迷信何もないんだと 言って侮辱はするんだけど
自分たちがいて もう丸の内の宝くじ売り場にざっと並んでるんですね
今最近それほど並んでるの見えないんですよ
理由はもう 400ぐらいあります
店が ずーっと並んでやります
だからより早くサービスできます
やっぱり現代社会ですね
今日は大吉とかね だからこの確実に希望を叶ってほしいとか思うと
まあもうちょっと具体的に生きる羽目にはなります
だから自分で頑張りますから
とにかく宝くじの 1等賞は当ててみて幸福になってみるそうと思ってしまうと
やっぱりそれが自力の道ではなくなっちゃうんですね
それも 結局は他力になっちゃうんです
それも他力になるんです
それで自分の力で何とかするんだという人にとっては大変なことになりまして
具体的に生きて生きてみなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
すごく合理的に生きてみなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
やっぱりお金計算する羽目になるんです
この店で時給が 600円で
もうちょっと 100メートル歩いたその店では 850円やと
ですから 私もいくらか余裕があって生活したいんだから
600円の店でバイトしてもらいますとかね
という結論じゃないでしょうに
ちょっと歩きますけど
そちらのもう手当が高いんだと
だからそちらで仕事をしますと
そういう風に考える羽目になるんです
お金も計算する羽目になるんです
だからそういうふうな生き方が仏教的な生き方なんですね
どうしてもスーパーでエビフライ売ってますけど
もう一つ 230円で二つ食べたいんですね
それでまあ六百六十円になっちゃいますからね
そこまではお金払いたくはないし
お金もないし だから仏教徒なら
まあどうせじゃあ昼ご飯なんとかして
ラーメンでもカップラーメンでも食べて
晩御飯に食べるぞと行って
もう六時半七時に行くんです
店閉めるギリギリのところ
行ったらまあ五十パーセントの売ってますから
やっぱり二つは一つの値段で買えるでしょうに
それで死んだ人はいないしね
皆様そういうことしないと思いますけど
あれ死にますからね 時間ギリギリだと言ってて
本当は死んだ人はいません
で 私もそういう午後どこか行くと別な用意と品物見て買ったことがありまして
買ってもその日で食べませんだから冷蔵庫に放り込んじゃって忘れちゃって
二日 三日 四日経ったところでまた出して食べましたけど
死んではないんですね
死んだ方が良かったなと思っているでしょ
死なないんです どんな程度でも
で 言いたかったのは やっぱり合理的に生きるということが仏道なんです
それでも不幸になるんだというなら
これはおかしいんです
本当は合理的に生きることっていうのは大変楽なんです
毎日風水で占ってみて
方位は今日は何でしたっけ？悪い神がいる
死神でしたっけね 鬼門だ
鬼門はどこですかとかね
で コンパスを持って 今日は東ですねとね
じゃあ今日は幸福はこちらで南から南から出られないんですね
壁だから じゃあ窓がありますからね
例えば台所は台所 小さな窓があったらそこから
ちゃんと出ていて で なんか日本でたくさん人々は億万長者にしてあげた人がいて
あれも風水なんとかテレビでは出ますけどね
彼が本なんか出したらもういきなり出すわ
もう全部売り切れというね
あと女性の人を見ますね
あの何  かなり細い感じ
なんとかっていうね 本出したらもう終わり
もうギネスにも載ってるみたいですよ
あの彼女の本の部数はどれぐらいというね
だからもう簡単にみんな億万長者にしてくれますけどね
見る限り日本人は そのまんまなんです
今日もＮＨＫテレビ番組からこのホームレスの若者もう子供なんですね
まあ高校とかに出た時にホームレスなんです
なんとかして助けてあげなくちゃっていうことで
大阪の方でね あの NPO の頑張ってる番組があったんですけどね
まあ現実はそれなんですけど
これでベッドのシーツは赤い黄色い色にしたところで
まあむちゃくちゃ幸福になったぞという人もいるんだからね
この家には赤い色は足りません
この家には黄色色は足りませんとかね
この家の大ところの水が出るところは
これもう南だからこれダメですよとかね
やっぱりこの場合は北でなければいけませんと
ではこれこれ建築上は無理ですから
どうします あ それが そしたら北に何かボールでもよろしいんだから
そちらで水を置いておいてくださいと
それでまあ仕事はバンバン回ってくるわ
みるみるうちに幸福になるんですよ
やってみてください だからあの人にいくらお金あげたっても大丈夫です
そんなもんじゃないんです
幸福になってからもう返ってくるお金の数々が
だからその幸福の神もよっぽどのバカで
あの南に水回りが南にあってはいけないんだけど
ガラスボールに東かいい方向でガラスボールに水入れただけでももう OK ですからね
勘違いするんで やっぱりこの家の水回りがこちらですと大丈夫やと
あの神連中っていうのは簡単に騙されますね
はぁ だからそういうふうなことを信仰して生きるよりは
玄関から出た方が楽なんです
毎日鬼門はずっとぐるぐるもう 360度回りますからね
だからそいつの気分に自分が合わせないで
自分が勝手に玄関から毎日出ると
その方がやっぱり楽だとは思いますよ
合理的に生きることが
で あの仏教の道になってくると
そういう風に この自分で頑張らなくちゃいけないってことになる
それは大変ではなくて
逆に楽なんです 占ってもらう必要もないし
新宿の占いのなんとか人に会わなくてもよろしいし
銀座にもいますからね
なんかゴシック系の服装を着てね
黒いもうベールで隠したりして
こんなもうぎりぎり怖くなるような
いろんな指輪とか目いっぱいつけたりして
ものすごいド派手なお化粧してね
あれやこれやと体にぶら下がっちゃって
もうお金も取るし あの
あの公園がありまして
あの立川で まあデパートですからね
やっぱり占いのところはもう並んでるんですね
で また一回 この三越の展示会がありまして
そちらちょっと作品見ようといったところで
やはり一箇所で人が並んでるんですね
あんだけやっぱりいるんですね
まあ全部運勢占い まあデパートでもやってます
だからこの そういうことに心配しなくてもいいっていうことになるんですね
だから ひいおばあさんのひいおじいさんのお墓参りしなかったんだからとか
あるいはひいかける 10とかね
10畳とかね まあそこまであるいは 160畳でもいいじゃないですかね
ひいひいひいひいひいおばあさんのお墓参りしてないんだから
私は今はちょっと病気にかかってますよとか
スーパーにいた時はもう後ろから自転車来てはめてしまったと
あとちょっと倒れまして
ちょっとかすり傷もしましたと
これあんたお墓参りしてないんだからって言うんだからね
私が聞くわ ではあんたアホやからか
あいつはあっち向いてホイで一つ蹴っ飛ばすとか良かったんじゃないかなとかね
私は悪い人間なんです
で これはもうひいひいひいおばあちゃんのお墓参りしてないんだから
そういうことになりましたと言った方が正しいんですね
周りを見て気をつけて歩けというのは正しくないんです
で まあ他力で幸福になろうと思っちゃうと
もう身動きできないほど硬直されますし
断続不幸に陥るんです
ああいう神秘的なことでね
すごい能力のある占い師やあれやこれやというのは
あれは嘘で 無茶金持ちの人々がやることないんだだからお遊びでそういう人々を買うんです
ちょっと占ってみてくれとかね
どうってことない 有名人でしょうし
もう根掘り葉掘り全部知ってるし
みんな だから占い師にも見事に占ってあげることもできるし
それでドーンともう万とかあげちゃうんですね
やることがないし お金もあるし
面白くないし 人生はね
だからそういうことをやろうではないか
それでじゃあ今度テレビに出てみようかとかね
そういう人の一言葉でも番組出来上がっちゃいますから
そういうものなんだよ
だからこの その占いのおかげで幸福になったんじゃなくて
その連中初めからもうやりてなんですね
初めからも金がもうもう小杉のように流れてる人々なんですね
秒のコマーシャルに億取ったりする人もね
世の中いるんだから で
そこまでっていうのは
その人は神様に恵まれたんじゃなくて
あの日本のコマーシャルなんとかもね
マイケルジャクソンが出たでしょうね
秒か秒なんです もっとかな
すごいコマーシャル長く作ってますけど
本人がそれだけって それにも億単位でお金払わなくちゃいけない
その人がずっと頑張ったことの結果でしょうに
芸術家としてもう徹底的に頑張って
世界的な人気者になっちゃって
スーパースターになっちゃったところに
どこかの会社がちょっとコマーシャルにどうでしょうかと
まあ秒は億転記しようと
嫌なら帰ってください
時間ないんだよという風に
向こう お願いします お願いしますと
そうなるんです だからそれが神様がやってくれたというならばね
はい それでは仏教の話にもうさらに戻りますけど
まず自分のことを自分でやると思ったら
この頭悪い人間にとっては大変なことやと思っちゃうんです
精神的な病気の人だったらね
精神的な病気でない人だったら
これは楽ちんやと 占ってもらう必要はないし
法水もいらないし 八卦もいらないし
もう血液型占いもいらないし
生まれた日にちで占いそれもいらない
いらないしね 服はラッキー
今日のラッキーカラーはなんでしょうか？とかね
考えてみてください 例えば
4月生まれた人の今日のラッキーカラーは緑色だった
だったら私は何着ればいいんですかね
そうするとその連中に聞いたら言うんです
まあ最低ハンカチぐらいでもいい
それで恵みの神が騙されますからね
で 朝のテレビでね 今日のラーメン食べたらうどん食べたら幸福になりますよとかね
今日は寿司食べたら幸福になります
そこまで言ってるんですね
服装で終わってないんです
今は すごい理性的な科学的な世界ですね
生きているのは この経済的豊かさでね
車で冷蔵庫でテレビでごまかしている携帯でごまかしているだけで
ちょっとそこを剥がしてみれば
もう原始世界そのものなんです
病気になったら病気の人の前で踊って病気治した昔のあのシャモン的な医者がいたでしょ
その世界そのまんまなんです
ただ この経済的な豊かさで
ちょっとカバー お化粧カバーというんですね
それは専門用語で 日本でもいろんな機械作って
最後にカバーをつけますね
カッコで それを化粧カバーというんです
テレビでもラジオでも何でもね
最後にカバーで化粧カバーなんです
中はすごいグツンいろんなものありますけどね
見えません 本当はこの
合理的に生きるということはとっても楽なんです
はい それは楽 それでもうまくいくますかというと
それでもうまくいかないケースがあるんですね
自分で頑張っても それでお釈迦様はそこを教えているんです
なんでうまくいかないのか
理由は 人間っていうのは考えて行動するんですね
判断するんですね 生きている
最近読んだ本によると
この 本にあったと言った方が皆様信じますから
すごい理性的だから 私はずっと言っていることですけど
フリーウィルというね
意思 自由意志っていうのはね
あるのかいと人間に 神がくれたみたいですけど
本当にあるのかと それであの脳科学的にいろいろ実験してね
fMRI とか何とかね
あの いろんな脳の機能診断する機械もありまして
それで実験すると 意識で判断に来る前に
もう脳がもうとっくに判断しているんだ
何やるのか で 脳がとっくにした判断は
それから意識で 論理で
あ こういうわけでこうしますと
自分が決めたと 違うやん
あなた先からそれ決めてやったんだった
脳が 一つの実験というのは
このある実験者にこの指を動かしてくださいということで
いろんなセンサーいっぱいつけちゃって
その気になったら指を動かしてください
それだけ そこであの指を動かしたくなった瞬間で言ってくださいと
それは何かボタンとかなんとか押すことか何とかでしょうね
とにかくその人が指を動かしたくなったと言って
また指を動かしてるんですね
その動かす動かしたくなった時間と動かす実行する時間の差は何なのかとかね
まあほとんどもう 0.0何秒の差なんですけどね
そこを測っているんですね
それで逆に別に脳の機能を測っているんですね
脳の機能を測ってみると
もうとっくにそれよりも先にもう脳が判断しているんだと
だからその時間も計算して
これぐらいこれぐらい時間差ありますよとかね
だからその人々の結論というのは
もうフリーウィルなんかあるわけじゃなくて
もう勝手に脳がもう判断しているんだと
時々人と相談するでしょう
こういう問題がありまして
私はどうすればいいんですかと
アドバイスしても意味がないんです
本人の無意識のところで脳がもうとっくに判断しているんです
私とそういうアドバイスを受けちゃうと結構喧嘩になるのはそういうわけで
私は脳の判断知ってるんです
だからいきなりすごい失礼で
あんたは本当はこれやりたくないでしょうにと
いえとものすごく怒るんですね
違いますよ そうだって
なんでやらないのかと
だからそれは思考妄想で引っかかっちゃって
やりたい やりたくない
やりたい やりたい やりたい
やりたくないというのも困っているんですね
基本的にはもう判断はできてあって
そこは何もれくすもなく
何もなく もう勝手に判断するんですから
それは管理もできんだから
これはフリーウィルにはなりませんよということで
やっぱり何か自由意志あるというこのかということはね
もう私は結構この本読むと
かなり前からね で 疑問には思ってますけどね
例えば歩いていると いきなりすごいもう穴が見える
そこで自由意志で判断しますかね
そのまま歩いて穴に落ちるか
あるいは穴は避けるかと
はい 皆さんどちらにする
これは九十パーセントのグループに入ってますね
他力で答え出てくると思って入ってる
避けます  普通の人間ならもう避けるに決まってるんです
だからそちらにどうやって自由意識ということを言えるんですかね
ここで私には 2つの道がありますと
はい どちらにしようかなとかね
はないんです 避けるに決まってる
小さな虫であっても同じことなんです
この場合はこの判断するんだぞと
それでこのいつでも私言うでしょ
選択が 2つあって困る場合は困らないでくださいと
どちらでもろくでもないものであるから
どちらを選んでも同じことよと
それを基本的に私はまあもう判断はそんなに曖昧優柔不断ではなくて
もう脳は勝手にやっちゃいます
それで脳が判断しないで悩んだならば
これ脳から見ればどうでもいいんです
立教大学に入るか明治大学
どっちでも受かってるんだからとか
困ったな困ったなとかね
脳から見ればどっちがでもどうでもいいんです
だからいくつかの人生の選択があって
困ったりしちゃうと もうじゃんけんでもコイン一つ上げて決めても
私は自分で実験したことがあります
実験だから何回もやったことあります
何かやりたいってことがあるんですね
でもこれは本当はやらない方がいいんですけど
でもやりたいなとかね
実際はやらない方がいいと知ってるんです
で じゃあどうしたことだから
じゃあコインで決めます
コイン投げたらやめろという結果が出たんですね
それで私は面白いことを
やっぱり一回ではダメで
これ三回ぐらい もうわかるでしょ
気持ちは やってはいけないとは知ってますけど
やりたいんだからやりますっていうことを決めてるんです
心が だから それでも悩んでコイン投げたらやめるという結果が出たにも関わらず
一回では決めない もう三回ぐらいやって
それで五回やってみたんです
五回でも三回やめろということになったんだからやったんです
だからそこで自分で分析してみると
まあそういうことかなと
最初からもうやりたがっていたんじゃないかなと
そこで知識に入ったところで
もうちょこちょこと余計な悩みが入ったんだけど
でも知識でないところでもう決まってるんです
はい それで で 脳が というか心がいろんなことを決めて我々生きているので
これどうにもならんですね
だから自分が幸福になりたかろうか
なりたいと誰でも思って頑張ってますけど
この判断はね 心がするんだから
結果がどうなるかっていうことは知れたものじゃないんだよね
悪い結果だなとわかってもやっちゃいますという
ことにはなります そこで仏教はそこをそのセクションを直してあげようとしているんです
もうもう瞬時にもう判断しているんですから
そこはもうどうしようもないんだから
もう勝手に判断してもいいんだけど
あなたには正解しか判断できないようにしてやるぞという
いうところを 心をもう根本的なところで直すちゃう
それが仏教の仕事なんです
他何も全然変わりは起こりません
普通に生きているんです
だから私による実験の中でも
その実験をやる羽目になったのは仏教の割り込みなんですね
仏教が割り込んできて
もう正しい判断はこれやと言ってるんですね
しかし ろくな仏教を解せない私は反対のことをやりたいんですね
しかし それでも私はその両方にも気づいてるんですね
それが普通の普通の人間よりはちょっと違うところですね
仏教が割り込んで これやめて
これは正解にならないんだから
これが正解だと言ってるんですね
言ってるんだけど 脳が
いえ それでもやっぱり面白いんだからこれやりなさいと
じゃあコインで決めるぞと
で コインもその回だけ見事にあのやめろっていう結果が出たのに
3対2でやっちゃったんだからね
で そこであの仏教は正解が自然に出てくるようにということで心を調教するんです
そうするともう自然にあの正解を結論を出すんです
それがフリーウィル自由意志があるんだからではなくて
無常だから因果法則だから可能なのだんですね
因果法則とフリーウィルも合わない単語なんです
しかし 仏教も人間には自由意志ありますよというふうには言ってありますけど
それはあんまり精密論で言ってるわけじゃないんです
精密論で考えれば因果法則だから
原因そろったら結果決まっているんだから
で こういうのはこの簡単な実験がありますよ
この優れた科学者の実験は要りません
あの皆様の家にあるやかんに水を入れてガスコンロの上に置いてください
で それそれでも冷たい冷水欲しいんだと
もらえませんよ 因果法則から見れば
温かい水も沸騰したお湯が出ますけど
もう冷たい水は出てきません
いくら踏ん張っても いくらお祈りしたって
何やっても不可能ですね
逆にあの 何て言いますか
冷凍庫でしたっけ そちらに水を入れて沸騰してほしいと
いくらお願いしても もうもうジェホワもアッラーももう断土堂々と待っていたてもありえないんです
氷は出ますけど その場
だから因果法則っていうのは
もうにフリーウィルっていうことはちょっと合わない
自由意志は だから因果法則によって我々はもうどうしようもない
どうしようもないではなくて
どうすることもできない
必ず達しなくてはいけない結論に達するんです
それで生きているんです
はい そこで結果見ればまずいんですね
我々は自分の気持ちで自分の好みで生きてみたところで
結果がまずいんですね
まずいんだからといって自分には気持ち変えることもできないんです
変える場合はすっごく心が攻撃するんです
嘘をつきたいのにも関わらず
仏教の戒律だから嘘言わないで我慢すると心がものすごく攻撃するんです
嘘を言いなさいよと この場合はと
いえ 仏教だから言いませんよと
いて言わないことにしても
そこで良い結果になりますが
心が納得しないんですね
では逆に心であんた不幸になりたいのかと
それはないんです いえ
不幸になりたくないんですが
この場合嘘を言った方がいいんじゃない？という答えなんです
だから心の判断が間違ってるんですね
不幸になりたい だからこうしな
嘘つきなさいと それが客観的に見ると
この判断が間違ってるんですね
じゃあどうしましょうかと
そこはもう厳しく これ直さなくちゃいけない問題なんですね
修行っていうのはそういうことになってくるんですね
だから仏教も科学と似ていて
1つの学問みたいな すごい知識みたいなものやと思っても
実践論は当然当然ありますね
それなく語れませんね
それであの心が判断して我々は生きていると
その方が楽なんですが
結果見るともうすごく悪いんですね
わがままで自分好き勝手に生活してみると
決して希望叶わないんですね
全部希望と反対の方向へ
金持ちになりたかったけどホームレスで終わっちゃうとかね
すごい人気者になりたかったんですけど
逮捕されちゃって全部なくなりましたとかね
あと 人気のタレントさんでもね
麻薬取ったりして捕まったりするでしょうね
それで降板されたりして
もうテレビでまた出ない出せなくなったりとかね
大変なことになるんでしょうね
だからそういう人々も頭ではわかってますし
まあそれでもやってしまうんでしょうね
何かやっぱり疲れてるんだからとか
仕事はもう大変厳しいんだからとかね
体が硬くもうクタクタ痛いんだからとかね
だからこれ苦しいでしょうね
麻薬使えと 使ってしまったところで全部パーになって終わってしまうんですね
仕事は忙しいではなくて
仕事がなくなっちゃう
お金でもいくらもありますからいいんじゃないかと言ったっても
もう貯金してた金もなくなってしまう
それから今まであっちこっち行ったら威張っていけたんだけど
握手を求めたりとか サイン求めたりとかね
それからみんな指を指すことになっちゃうとかね
あの あの人よと あの今麻薬で逮捕された人よとかね
だから だから信じられない不幸に陥っちゃうんですね
そこを落としたのは誰かというと
自分の心なんですね しかし
自分の心は不幸にはなりたくなかったんです
だから心がバカということになっちゃうんですね
そこで私はそこをもっと具体的に
冗談で この何かあの覚えやすい短い言葉で喋った方がいいんだから
そういう言葉たくさん喋ってますけど
あの正解出したければ
自分の気持ちと違うことやってくださいと
自分の気持ちが何かやりなさいと言ったら
それをやらないで反対のことをやってみてくださいと
うまくいきますよ だからその言葉を作ったのも
やっぱり心は本来無知バカっていう真理に基づいて
だったらもういい加減逆らってへんてこりんなことやった方がいいんじゃないかなと
だから自分の気持ちが言ってることに反対のことも
へんてこりんなことやってみると結構うまくちゃいます
いきますよ 嘘をつきたくなったならば
そう自分が嘘をついたいでしょ
ではつかないことにするぞとか
今この人怒鳴ってやろうかという怒鳴らないこと
ということで この気持ちが言っていることの反対を付けてみると
時々正解が出てくる場合もあります
そういうわけで 心は常に揺らいでいるんです
心はもう何でもかんでも最初からもうもう判断しているんですね
この皆様 この先入観という言葉が英語ではPREJUDICEという言葉があるんです PREJUDICE PREJUDICE
というのはPREJUDGMENTという意味のなまりというか
そこ言葉で合成している言葉なんですね
だから先入観というのは日本語訳は先入観
固定概念というかね 最初から判断していることにもう一つ日本語の単語があるはずなんです PREJUDICE
偏見  ん？先見？偏見ではないわけですね
潜在意識  ん？ 潜在意識
ま 先入観ということなんです
もう一つ単語あるはずなん
あるべきです はずではなければ
最初からもう決するんだって
もう裁判を行うという
固定概念  思い込みですか
ん？思い込みまた違いますね
先入観  とにかくはまあ先見
先入観 難しいんですね
この10%の部分を喋るべきことは
この90%のところで喋っているんだから場が違うと思いますけど
それで この先見で生きている我々は誰でも
これで期待通りにはいかないんですね
心は幸福を期待しているんですね
これをやれば幸福だと先見で決めちゃうんですね
例えばこの他力の人類も 90%
の地球上の人間も あれ先見でやっぱり他力だろうと決まっているんです
それでクタクタ不幸になっているのに
世界が人殺しでいっぱいなのに
憎しみや争いやね もう借金やらもう切りがない
苦労 不幸ばっかりなんですけど
それでももうやっちゃいますね
先生 予断という言葉 予断
あらかじめ断ずる 決めて
予断 漢字は見ないとちょっと頭に入らないですね
予約の予に判断  はい 予断という意味ですものね
はい 予断でみんな生きてますけど
結果的にはもうものすごく大変最悪だから
心にはもう悩んだり揺らいだり
もうものすごく悩む羽目になっちゃう
これって心のせいなんですね
だからといって予断はやめたくはないんですね
理性で判断はしたくないんです
麻薬は悪いと分かってもやめたくはないんです
薬球 タバコは悪いと分かってもやめたくはないんですね
これどうなったのかというと
大変な不幸な結果になるんですね
窮状 窮状というんですか
だけでは済まないでしょうね
それから精神的にもう立場がなくて困るところ大変でしょう
だから自分の心がやったことなんです
だから心にはこの予断病気がありますから
もう揺らぐことっていうのは当たり前
安らぎはもうありえないんです
安らぎ期待したっても
これありえないんです
予断 予断でももう行動しますからね
あらかじめ決めて行動するんだからね
調べてはい 判断しますよ
ないんです で これで全ての生命がそういうことで生きてるんですね
だから これ脳の構成でもあって
心の構成でもありますから
これ変えることもできません
しかし もっと先に仏教
ブッダだけ言ってみたんですね
言ってみたら全て因果法則なんですね
だから予断で生きることもどうしようもないんですね
予断に達するのも因果法則なんですね
じゃあそこをちょこちょこといじってみようと
そこで予断に達する場合は
心は当然貪瞋痴を使うんですね
貪瞋痴が自己愛なんですね
自我愛なんですね 自我という
妄想概念ね ありまして
幻覚がありまして この自我という幻覚で自我を守るために必要な警備はもう3種類ですね 3
群ですね これは貪瞋痴なんですね
だからそちらがもう決めるんですね
こうしましょう こうしましょう
こうしましょう もうとっくにもう決まってるんですね
だから貪瞋痴が決めた予断だから
当然それに逆らった方が成功ということに私がしたんですね
貪瞋痴があって構いません
もうまだまだ あっても失敗したくないんだから
それなら論理的な答えは自分の気持ちに逆らうことなんです
だから貪瞋痴があっても成功するしたければ
そういう道 その態度を取らなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで貪瞋痴がある限り
自我愛がある 自我幻覚がある限り
あるいは予断というファンクションがある限り
心は常に揺らぐんですね
常に悩む羽目になるんですね
何やっても期待の結果じゃない
何喋っても期待の言葉ではない
何考えても考えるべきではべきものではない
何を行ってもやるべきではないんですね
これだったらもう日常心が揺らぐ羽目になるんです
安らぎは瞬間でも感じられません
で 安らぎは何なのかっていう疑問になって
お釈迦様が贅沢三昧や出家のくせに
お釈迦様の教えは何やと言ったら
かなり安らぎの教えなんです
修行もしないしね だから他宗教家にも非難
非難されるんだ だからある他宗教家がブッダに攻撃するんですね
あなたそんなにも楽に安らぎに生きることがすごいと言うならば
あなた方よりはコーサラ国王の方がかっこいいでしょう
もうむちゃくちゃもう国のインドの国々の中で一番大きい国で
もうかなり豊かなもう国王だけは豊かなんですね
とにかく でも使っているものといえば
もう人間にはそもそもできない贅沢グッズばっかしで
窓は閉めて寝られるだけではなくて
窓にカーテンまであったんですね
当時に これってすごい高いんですよ
機械で作る編むものじゃないんだから
ものじゃないんだから
王様の部屋のカーテンだから
かなり究極に高級な糸で
みんなもうすごい丁寧にデザインを入れて編むものなんですね
何年もかけて で 枕やらベッドやらもうもう何でもありで
そこでそういう風に贅沢に寝る
あの国王のが楽じゃないかと
お釈迦様はね あんた何も研究しないで調べようともしないで
よくももう判断ばっかりするんだと
そこで科学者の立場は言うんだよ
データがなくて データを取って調べてモデルを作って調べて言いなさいという態度なんです
それでももうしょうがない
あんたに説明しますよと
言ってコーサラ国王があれでこれでとか
あらゆることで悩むことを全くなく
音にも悩むことなく 触覚
味覚 そういうことにも悩むことなく
政治家等の政治のことを宮殿のことをまるっきりも悩むことなく
一切思考を止めて究極の安らぎを感じて
だいたい 1週間ぐらいいられますかと
ああ これは無理やと でしょ
じゃあ 1週間でなければ
まあ 6日間 まあ 6 日間も無理やと
じゃあ 5 日間  4 日間 じゃあ 3 日間
じゃあ 1 日 無理 じゃあ半日
無理だ では 1時間くらいできますか？と言ったらできません
と言ったら じゃあ一瞬でもできますかと
全ての悩みがなくなった
何も認識もしない 思考もない心で究極の安らぎを感じていられますかと
じゃあ瞬間というのは
ただ この人は瞬間でもできませんと
それはありえないんだと
あんた ありえないといい加減なことを言うなよと
私は瞬間ではなくて  1時間ではなくて
半日ではなくて  1日 ではなくて
その気になったら 1週間で見られます
それなら誰が贅沢ですかと
それなら参りましたと
お釈迦様の方が桁違い
はるかに贅沢ですと 対話があるんです
ということ そちらにもある論点が心は揺らぎますということです
揺らぐと苦しいんですよ
平和じゃないんです クタクタ悩むんです
心 だから足が痛い 腰が痛い
そんなのはもう話にならんもう
旦那の帰りが遅いんだからとかね
そんなのは冗談でしょう
どうにもなることでしょうに
そんなこと しかし 私たちの心が瞬間たりとも予断の正気で判断しながらいるんだだから
瞬間でも怯えて 瞬間瞬間も怯えて生活している
揺らぐ心で生きてるんです
それで悟った人にはそれがないんだよという
この偈の意味なんです
サンタンタッサマナンホウティ
彼の心がもう揺らぎがないんだと
サンターワーチャーヤカムジャ
言葉も行為もない で話が終わります
それでサンマダンニャーヴィムタッサという言葉が入りましたね
それは修行の結果で正しく見るということはね
気づきの実践でしょうし
それでヴィムッタ 解放されてますね
貪瞋痴から解放されているんですね
だから貪瞋痴から解放されても先入観がありますよ
それが基本的な生き方だから
先入観なくなったわけじゃないんです
もう安心なんですね 先入観ではなくて
予断はあります でももう決めたことをやってるんです
しかし 決めたんだけど困ったな
それはありえないんです
私たちにとっては 心がやりなさいということと
意識が勉強した概念の世界がやめろやめろということで
いつでも戦っているんですね
それがなくなっちゃうんです
それでもすごく行動が早くなりますよ
私たちは考えて考えて考えて動くんだから
やりたいんだけど でもあれでもね
あれもありますし これもありますしとかね
うまくいくかもわからないしとかね
どんな結果になるかもわからないんだけど
でもやりたいんだけど
やっぱりやめたいんだけど
どうしようかとかね あんたどう思う？とか人に聞いたりとかね
この人やれって言ったらもうその言い訳にしてでもやっちゃったら自己責任なくなるんではないかとかね
人に聞くのはそういうわけなんです
若者 私にも聞いたことありますよ
大学 2つ受かって どちらにすればいいかと
私はじゃあこちらにしてくださいと言っちゃうと私の責任になるでしょ
それからうまくいかなかったら
だからそういうことでもう悩むんだから遅いんですよ
行動は それからやりたいことがたくさんあって
悩んでいる間でも時間切れでできなくなってるんですね
だから私たちはもうやりたいことも 1億分の 1 もやっているのかどうかよくわからないんですね
もう実行できない もうやろうかな
やめようかな どうしようかな
人に聞こうかな 誰に聞けばいいかなとか
それに結構時間いっちゃって
もう締め切り それは実行できないってことになっちゃう
それにまたさらにやっぱりやった方がよかったな
さらに悩み始めるになっちゃうんですね
そういうことで この俗世間にいる人々はものすごく遅いんです
何の能力も効率っていうのはもう全くない世界で生きているんです
全部なくなりますよ この修行して
この心の問題解決すれば悩みっていうのはすっくと消えちゃいますから
心を決めたことをやればいいんです
だからその心の状況が阿羅漢に達した人の心の状況だと
それもちょっと想像しにくい状況かもしれませんね
もう消えちゃって もうずっと安らぎでいる
その人が予断で決めることは何であっても
いつでも正解に決まっているんです
芸として十分でしょうと思いますけど
質問とかあれば皆さん
皆さんは何かご質問などございますか？ じゃあ質問コーナーにします
次の芸に入っちゃうと結構疲れます
はい マイクを 自由意志がないというようなお話だったと思うんですけれども
それは因果法則というのにそぐわない概念であると
その自由意志がないというのはもうちょっとお尋ねしたいんですけども
例えばですね 何か条件が決まれば結果が決まるっていうのはわかるんですけども
その条件の一つを何かちょっと変えるっていうのは
それは自由意志とは考えられるんですか
あの普通の日常生活では自由意志があるような現象が見えますね
そこは否定してないんです
だから 一番最初の説法で出した最初に出した例もね
自分で歩いているのに
自分で座っているのに
よくもあんたパラカーラと呼んだよとかね
その場合は自由意志という言葉でお釈迦様を攻撃しているんですね
ここまで来たのはあなたの気持ちで来たんじゃないのかと
これは誰か他力でもう来させたわけじゃないだろうと
そこであの これは哲学を語るレベルの問題なんですね
ああいう人々っていうのは
もうギリギリの思惟家たちでというか
妄想家たちでね その場合
すごい厳しく論理でもう喋りますけど
日常生活の中では お釈迦様はすごいシンプルな言葉で語りますね
だからその場合は自由意志っていうのはチェータナですね
意志というね 言葉もありますしね
で だからチェータナが意志ですよ
それが自由でしょうかと
インディペンデンですかね
例えばですね あまりいい例じゃないかもしれませんけども
料理を作るとしますね
カレーライスを作ろうと思って
鍋にじゃがいもとか人参入れてぐつぐつ煮て柔らかくすると
あとカレー粉を入れるわけですけども
カレー粉をちょっとやめて味噌を入れようかなと
そしたらカレーライスじゃなくて味噌汁になっちゃったというふうになって
これは美味しい味噌汁だったということで
突然変わってしまったと
そういうふうに まあ自由意志の例としてはちょっと変な
そういうふうに全然思ってたものと違うものを作っちゃうとかですね
自分が思ってたものじゃないものを
でもそういう例で見ても
やっぱりこれ自由意志だというふうに証明する例っていうのはね
ないんです そのケース
具体的に別に変な例じゃないんでしょうね
野菜も入れて 味噌も入れて
もうちゃんと煮ている
目指しているのに カレー
本当はカレー粉を入れる予定でしたけど
やっぱり味噌入れたと
なんでその判断したのかと
気が変わったら  やっぱり何か原因があるんでしょう
私も自分のことで実験するんだから
私もそうやって突然気持ち変える
変えますよ 突然 で 変えるんだけど
私の場合はやっぱり決めた通りやるつもりはないと
何か変なことをやって
変な結果を出してみて試したいという気分が出てくるものですね
だから私は時々カレー粉も入れたのに変わらず
やっぱり味噌も入れちゃおうと自分はやるんです
それで最悪なんですけど
料理出来上がったらね
なのにやっちゃいます
なんでかというと なんかちょっとワンパターン決まってるパターンでやるのはなんか嫌になっちゃうんですね
それで何回何回も もうもうもうもう
なんで自分がこれ食べなくちゃいけないんだ
自分にも怒りながらね
こんなまずいものとかね
一回だけこのネパールカレーのいくつかスパイス入ってる箱があって
そこで料理の仕方が書いてあったんですね
1これこれ合わせて 次これこれで
3これこれで それから順番でこれ炒めて
これまずこれ入れて それからこれとかね
ある日 読みながら順番でやってみたんですね
その時でも入れる材料は勝手に変えたんですね
あの 例えばあのカボチャもこの時間でカボチャ入れてくださいとかね
この時間でこれ入れてくださいとか
それはなくて もう家にあった野菜でまあ入れちゃったんですけど
結構美味しかったんです
それでもあの材料はあの書いてる通りでもないんですね
いくつかの材料はなかったんですけど
その代わりにもう冷蔵庫にあったものでやっちゃったんですけど
料理の順番があの紙に書いてあった時にしたら
今日なかなか美味しいんじゃないと
美味しいでしょと だったらその通りやればいいでしょ
それでは面白くなくなっちゃうんですね
それで決めたのは もし誰かが来て料理する羽目になったら
しっかりとこの順番で作った方がいいんだと
それと何も文句言わせずに済みますと
だから自分が自分で実験しているんですね
こうするべきであっても変えるというね
その場合 自分がやっぱり何か変なところ
変なことをしたいというね
そこはもうずっと子供の頃から一貫してあるんですね
ドグマは嫌なんですね
決まりと言った途端 ものすごくもう上がってくるな
決まりですかねとか 小さい時から
でもこの私はもうよくも坊主通して育てたなと思いますよ
長老たちがね やめろと言ったら終わりですね
私は 命令は絶対聞かないです
なのに長老たちはすごいというのは
もう一度でもこうこうやりなさい
こうしなさいとかはないかったんですね
いつでもいろいろ状況を判断して
まあこれだからこれでこれでまあこうなることですねというだけで
それで判断は自分でするんです
一回小さい時に本堂のところからものすごいスピードで走ってきたんです
長老が例えば前に椅子
横になる椅子があって
そこに座っているんですね
で 階段ありまして 階段が降りませんだからね
昔は 上からもう 4つ  6つ
7つぐらいあったんで
全部いっぺんに飛んだんです
で 長老が見ていると知らなかったんですね
道路はもう決まっていつにも必ずいるんですけど
あんまり気にしないでもう誰かと遊んでいたと思いますけど
ものすごい勢い出してきて
これもなんか全部上行っちゃってね
大変恥ずかしいことになっちゃったんですね
長老ももう全部もう祖師にもバレちゃったんですね
全部出て またおとなしく入ろうとすると
長老がもうあんまり何やこれって言ったらもうダメなんですね
長老にことわって出家は走ってはいけないと言ってるのはそういうわけです
そこをそういう風に言ったんですね
それでね お釈迦様が出家はね
たとえ子供であっても走ってはいけないと言ってますけど
それはそういうわけですよ
だから何も言ってないですよ
私には それでしっかりそれを覚えて
自分で判断して 自分で自分の人生を築いていくんですね
他のお坊さんたちはそれほど頭が良かったわけじゃないんですけど
まあいろんなお坊さんたち
いろんなことを言いますからね
これはダメ あれダメという人の人まで嫌いになっちゃうんですね
あの人は嫌いやと それでいろいろ機会見てるんで
攻撃してやろうかなとかね
なんか言葉を間違うところとかね
何か自分でも間違い起こすところで待ってるんですね
見つけたとたん言うんですね
年上の長老たちですけどね
あちらに攻撃するんです
だからそういう生活だったら育ちにくいでしょう
でも自分のあの大長老はもう何のことなく
で育ててみせたんですね
ですからこのそうやって
なんかちょっと違うことをやりたいとかね
ちょっと変わったことをやらなきゃ面白くないと
いうことがあるんだから
そういう私は突然そういう判断はします
が これ自由意志なのかという
結局は ずっと一貫して変わったことをやりたいということに支配されているんだけど
だから私にとってこの伝統的なものを学ぶっていうことは結構難しいんです
例えば日本の茶道とかはね
もうダメだと思いますよ
今はないんだけど もし私の二十歳ごろ茶道の先生についたならば
その先生結構もう殴られると思いますね
もし学んだならば もしそれが挑戦だと言ったならばやります
これには反 そうといったらもうそう
じゃあ 1ヶ月そこでやってみそうではないかと
そこで逆らうんです それで必ず 1ヶ月でびっくりするほどの結果出すんです
それ能力あるんじゃなくて
あの性格なんですね 変わったことやりたいというね
それで 3ヶ月とか 半年間かかるんだったら作動できるまではと言ったら
それは必ずかかります
私はもう確実に 1ヶ月間で終わっちゃうんです
何のことなんです それ能力じゃないんですね
別な性格なんですね 働いている
そういう挑戦だったら覚える
やるかもしれませんだけど
もう習ってないんだからわからないんだから
もし私が作動を習ったならば
私の作動っていうのは想像できないものになると思います
もう全く違うことやっちゃいます
だから自由意志って本当に
その なんか条件を自分で変えているように見えても
それはなんか論理的に思考してこれがいいだろうと判断して条件を変えているとか
あるいはその時の気分であるかもしれませんけども
なんらかのそれの条件付けでその条件を変えたという理解ですかね
そうですね だから条件はいつでも変えられますけど
それが自由なのかというね
例えば夜電気ついていると寝られないという人がいるとしましょう
あなたは自由だから 今日はいっぱい電気つけたまま寝てくださいと
できるんですかね じゃあ唐辛子いっぱい入ってる食べ物食べてみてくださいとか
私は食べられますけど
皆様は食べられますかね
それでも罪は罪で 善は善だと
だからそこら辺はすごいすごい素晴らしい教えだと思いますよ
善と悪とも自分の個人と自由意志とかね
それで関係ないんです
客観的な因果法則で この行為にこの結果ということだから
例えば自由意志があるならば
自分の心は貪瞋痴で汚れているんですね
貪瞋痴で汚れてるんだからどうしようもないでしょ
私は間違った判断するの
私の責任でもないでしょうに
だからその結論を出さなくちゃいけないんですね
貪瞋痴に 例えばものすごく激怒しましたとすると
そうすると私の思考も言葉も行為も激怒によって支配されていて
何言ったかやるとやっちゃったと
人を殴ったと でもそういう条件だから
私には何て言いますか
自由がなかったんだと
だから罪がないと言っても
仏教では罪なんです 日本の裁判で責任能力という言葉が使っているでしょ
責任能力なかったんですから無罪とかね
その問題に あれは天野さんでしたか？弁護士ですから
これを聞いたら 私は私は認めませんと
それは 責任能力あるかないか
くだらんことするな あんたも考える必要ないんだと
悪いことしたならば そのままビシビシ法律でできるだけ裁きなさいと
だからこれは参考に聞こえますけど
その通りだとしょうがないんだ
本人が仏教を学んで学んでいるんだから
やっぱりすごく優しい
もう犯罪を犯した人にもすごく優しい何とか態度できるんじゃないかなとは考えてますけど
それを慈しみでは慈しみではないかと
私はそんなところではないんですね
私の判断で厳しいんですね
私はそれはもう因果法則のところから言っているところなんですけど
だから例えば精神的な判断能力がない人は人を殺すと
だからちょっと情状何とか酌量
なんだらかんだらとかすると
言われたら人を殺す人だったらみんなそうでしょ
判断能力があったならば人を殺せないでしょうに
人を殺して もう計画立てて殺しても
突然突発的 突発的に殺しても
人に頼んで殺してもいいわけじゃないでしょうに
だから判断能力あったとは言えませんよ
判断能力なかったんだからこそ人を殺しちゃったんです
判断能力がなかったんだから無罪と言っちゃうと
だから単純に行為に結果なんです
放火したいという放火犯人が家に火をつける
子供 家の子供が遊ぶ マッチ見つかったぞとかね
ライター見つけたぞとかね
これで遊びましょうと言って遊んだところで家に火がつくと
でも結果同じでしょ まあ子供たちは遊んでいたんだから
まあ大したことないとか
でもないでしょうに 家が火事になっちゃったんだから
だから行為に結果なんです
だから行為を起こす場合は
行為を起こしたいというチェタナが生まれるんです
そこを汚れていている場合は
あの気づきが働いていることが自由なんですね
気づきが働いていると
決して悪いことはしません
気づきが働いていないと
もう意思がもうすぐ判断はするんです
だから自由に達する道は気づきなんですね
サティですね  はい 先生
さっきの哲学者のエピソードのところで
その無我だ アナッタという概念があるから
その 例えば自分の意思でやってるわけでもないし
他人の意思でもやってるわけでないっていう言い方をどうしてお釈迦様はせずに
そのあなたの意思でっていう風な形で最後落としてしまわれたわけなんですか
それは自分の意思ですからでしょ
だから一人一人が心を持ってるでしょうに
そこで生きているんだから
そこは人の話聞きませんよ
自分が判断して生きているんです
これは心のことなんです
じゃあその無我っていう
それは無我でしょうに
我があるわけないでしょう
どこに  ないです 意思はあるけど
その意思は変化するから我というものはないです
我は全体的にどこにもないことでしょうに
神と同じなんです 人間の妄想概念以外何でもないんです
我がないんだからといって
こちらでちゃんと予断で判断して生きているんです
だから個が予断で判断して生きていることが
お釈迦様はその人に言ったんです
あんたでしょうにと来たのは
私の予断に外から何にも言うこともできないんです
例えばお釈迦様が だから私の実験そうでしょう
だから外から学んだ仏教的な道徳もあって
自分の心がもうそれとちょこっとこんな変なことだからやりましょうと言ってること気分があって
そこで意識と自分の予断がもうちょっと困っているでしょうに
それでコイン投げてみたらやめなさいと結果出たにも関わらず
自分の予断が言ったことをやるんです
やっちゃったんだから
だから結局自分がやったことになるんです
そうですね 自分がやったことだけど
それが自分がやったけど
それが自由意志かどうかっていうのはまた別個の話で
これはもう成り立たないということなんです
あの自由意志イコール自我でもありますね
本当は それは単純純粋ロジックですけど
あの 例えば私の体なら私の好きなようにできるはずでしょうに
だから親が反対しているのに
子は穴開けるでしょ 体に
私の体だからと でもダメ
やめろと もう 18歳だからね
いちいち言うなよと そこでこの自分が自由ということを強調しているでしょう
だから自由っていうのは自分好きなようにできるっていう意味なんですね
ではできますかと  何でもできるってわけじゃないです
何でもと言ったって もうほとんど体で穴開けるか開けないか程度でしょうに
それもその人はなんで穴開けることに判断するかというと
自分の周りは穴開けてるんだからでしょうに
そちらにやらせているんです
周りの友達がみんなあちらこちら穴開けて
いろんな金属をいろんなものつけてるんだから
もう自分でもやらなくちゃいけないと決まってるんですね
だからそれをやめろという親に攻撃するだけ
本人が偉そうに自由意志を強調してますけど
あれ自由じゃなくて仲間の奴隷以外何でもないでしょう
だからその場合は自由は効いてないんです
だから自由イコール自我
エゴですね だからもともとエゴ存在しないならば
まあありえなくなったんです
だから自由意志がなかったら
罪を犯したっても意味がない
それはダメです 因果法則ですから
行為に結果っていうのはもう誰にも関係ないものなんです
だからまあ 嘘をつくなかれとか
殺すするなかれというのには
まあもう例えば漁師がもう魚を取るしかないんだからといって罪になりませんよ
そんな話はないんです
いい結果はあります 成り立たない
それにしてでも 例えばブッダの言うような心の安らぎをその方向を目指すのであれば
そっちの方が善であって
別に地獄の方が善だと思う人にとっちゃ
裏返った形に自由意志が形成されるっていうふうな感じ
例えばブッダの言う心の安らぎっていうのを目指すのであれば
善と悪っていう方向ははっきり分かれる
その方向つきますけど
例えば裏返して地獄のその無限地獄を目指すのが価値観の人だったら
ブッダの言う善は悪というふうに設定はできますよね
まあただのね 言葉の遊びですけどね
まあまあそれはその通りで
論理的にはそうなりますけど
心は基本的に幸福を目指してるんですね
苦しみは嫌なんですね
だから現実的にはありえないんです
そうですね そこは忘れたい感じです
ですから ブッダのところに解かれた善は善で
悪は悪でも 私は無限時空に行きたいんだから
その もし心にその自由があれば
もし心に自由があると仮定する
一人が解脱の道を決めると
その人は嘘をつかないことが善で
一人が自由があるんだから無限時空を目指しているならば嘘をつくことが善になるんですね
だって自分の目的に達するからね
しかし 心がその自由がないんです
心はやっぱり安らぎ 幸福を目指すのです
苦しみは嫌がるんですね
他にあのも少し一般的な
あ すいません じゃあマイクを
先ほど長老が決まりを守るのが嫌いだというようなことを言われましたけども
仏教の世界っていろんな戒律なんかがあって
決まりもたくさんあると思うんですけれども
我々の社会でもいろんな管理とか決まりとかありましてですね
私個人もそういったものを守るのがすごく好きじゃないんですけれども
そういういろんな決まりがたくさんある中で
生き抜いていくために必要な考え方っていうのはどういったものなんでしょう
簡単ですね アホが決まったことは守らなくてもいいんです
しっかりと意味があって
決まりには論理的にちゃんとしたサポートがあるならば
言わなくたっても守るもんでしょうに
例えば赤信号は渡らないぐらいのことはね
あまりきつくないでしょ
これはちゃんとした理由がある決まりでしょ
それは苦しくないんです
それは私も守ります 他はTPOを考えて守りますけど
すっごく悔しいんで 何か一言葉でも悪口言います
その場合は ただの決まりっていうのね
だからあの決まり決める資格はね
みんなにあるわけないんですよ
だから私はブッダの決まりはね
必ず守る決まりはしっかりやりまして
まあそれぞれいいやっていうこと決まりもあります
もう守るべきなんですけど
論理的に しかし そこはよく中身はわかってるんですね
中身わかっているんだから
お釈迦様はこの決まりはここまで考えになって決めたことで
これはこの条件で決めたんだからとかね
はい 一番私が破っている決まりの中で一つ明確なものっていうのは
衣の場合なんですね 衣っていうのは一着しか持ってはいけないんですね
どうしてもというのであれば
余分腰巻きだけ 1枚あってもいいんです
私の部屋で衣なん着あるか自分でもわからない
全然それでお釈迦様の決まりは破ってますけど
全然気にもしてない しかしよくわかりますね
一着しかあるとさすが便利だろうとかね
さすが気をつけて生活だろうとかね
で 昨日家で部屋で着ていた衣もそれほど古くないんだけど
こうやってちょっと開けてみると
こちら穴があるんですね
どんな衣を見ても どこかでダメージがあるんですね
穴がある まあ線香でしょうね
おそらく だからどこで穴が開けたか
それはわかりませんし
決まりは穴が開いた衣は着てはいけないんです
また これまたすごい情けない生き方になったりするんです
穴の大きさを見て まあこれでっかくなったってもう着るでしょうと
これは 指を入れるぐらい穴だったらもう
衣としてはもう失格なんです
そこは自分でまあ直さなくちゃいけないんですね
そう そういう決まりあるんだけど
あまり気にしないって
なぜかというと 当時インドでね
こんなでっかい衣っていうのは 1,000万ぐらいの価値があるでしょうね
現代的な気分で言えば
だって作るためには軽々と半年間かかりますからね
綿から もう手でもう機械もなかったしね
これは 3着でもよろしいという言うことは言えないでしょうね
だから拾ったもので作りなさいよと
インド人が迷信だらけでしょ
お釈迦様はそこをうまく使うんです
バラモン人はいくらか金があるんです
バラモン人が金があるし
もうバクバクと金取っちゃうしね
祈祷やったりしてね それでもう生地とか結構あるんです
しかし 昔インドでまああのネズミにネズミが噛んだりする場合ありますね
服は これそんなに珍しいことではないんです
昔 私は在家の時でも 自分の家でも
なんかネズミがもう母親の何とかとかね
ネズミが噛んじゃってね
大騒ぎになったこともありましたけどね
どうしようか困ったなとかね
ここでバラモン人というのは
例えばネズミが服を噛んじゃうと
いくら高価なものであっても大変不吉なことが起きたと
これは触ってはいけないんですね
それでスティックでこの服を持って
こうやって持っていくんです
持っていって墓場に捨ててくるんです
お坊さんたちはじーっと待ってるんです
待っていて持っていくんです
一人のお坊さんがもうちょっと
ちょっと態度が私と似ているのかわからないんだけど
あのバラモン人がそこを捨てて身を清めて沐浴をして家に戻るんですけど
このお坊さんどんなことよく知ったんですね
これは向こうを捨てることになってますよと
だから捨てたゴミですから
やっぱり先 何でしたっけ？勝ちでしょ
先に取った人がね で このお坊さんがもう自分の衣はボロボロで壊れているし
新しい生地が欲しいし
だから先に行ったんです
行ってバラモン人が捨てるところで
その人に目の前でどんどんとそれ取ったんですね
そこわざとやったと思いますよ
ただバラモン人がびっくりして
あ それ手で触るんです
あなたもう立派な人でしょうにと
すごく無効な感じ これネズミに噛まれたものだと不幸になりますよ
と言ったら その人にすごい説教してね
あんた方の迷信はね これを愚か者の迷信
無知だからやってますよ
私たちにとってはこんなものはとても幸福やと
虫が噛んだんだからといってね
大丈夫よ 心配しないでくださいと
だからそれはもうバラモン人からかうのはいいんだけど
もしバラモン人たちが虫が噛んだらそこら辺はナマステ不快ませということになったならば
また困るのもしょうがない
そういうケースも一応勉強のためにね
ケースはいろいろ記録していますけどね
だからやっぱり例なんですね
だからそれぐらい高価な衣で
これっていうのはだいたい衣一着というのは千五百
二千円で買えます これ全部ミャンマーのものだから
二千円で結構立派なもの買えますからね
だからどうすればいいんですかね
一千万ぐらいの価値あるものやどうにやっちゃうと
かえってカルト的になるでしょ
現代時代で衣をすごく丁寧に使って
丁寧にあれやこれやとやっちゃうと
なんかえらいカルト 道元さんがそこを見て
衣に大変大事にする中国でね
みんなと一緒に坐禅していると
ある中国人が衣を体にかけるんです
坐禅する時は普通仕事するとかは置いておいて
で 汚れないように 壊れないように
それで坐禅に入る時はものすごい丁寧になんかすごい紙のなんとか御神体持ったような感じで
こうやって頭の上に乗せてすごく礼をして
それから起きてこれ感動するんですね
道元さんが それでその正法眼蔵で衣の巻って何かも書いてありますからね
それぐらいすごいことやと
そんなことやっちゃうと
なんかカルト的に見えない
しかし他の決まりはしっかり守りますよ
衣をいい加減に使わないとかね
まあだから 何でもかんでも守るんじゃなくて
やっぱり守れなかったら迷惑という決まりもありますよ
それは私は何のことなく守りますね
守ったら迷惑ということは守りません
昨日は用事があって銀行に行ったんですけど
まああの決まり この決まりで名乗り入る
ものすごく怒鳴ったんです
うるさいんだと あんたら
いい加減にしろ 怒鳴ったところでもう黙って
向こうは決まりで動くんだから
機械だから 人間じゃないんだからね
判断もできないし それで一応仕事をやってくれたんですけど
でももうものすごい怒って
もう怒ってはないんだけど
時間ないし あと一分待って仕事始まらなかったら
私が出した資料全部返してもらうぞと
新宿に行く 初めからもう新宿に行く予定でしたからね
まあ新宿の銀行はすごい大きいし
なんかもう行ったら家に行ったような感じで
随分もうピシピシとやってくれるんで
もう信じられない速さで
で 冗談になにこにこ笑いながら人も多いしね
まあそのセクションでは
だからまあ新宿と笹塚にも銀行あるんだからね
毎回うるさいんですね
だからお寺にいくらかお金を送ったんですけど
で これはあの 証拠になるものは何かないかと
そんなのはありません
それは何回も送っていますが
あなた方の銀行から それはもうそうかもしれませんだけど
私はこの人にお金を送るってどんな証拠を出せばいいんですか？と
これが証拠でしょうにと
この人にお金を送ってるんだよっていう
それは何聞いてるんですか？と言ったら
いえ もう現金は だからだから何が違いますか
それ だからこの銀行口座もありますからね
銀行口座からお金を下ろしてないんですね
だからだから銀行口座
だから銀行口座のお金を入れて
私の手にお金あるんだからでしょうに
わからないのかと だからもうカードもあげましたしね
銀行の だからあんたにカードもあげましたから
うるさいんだと言って
もう行って座ったんですね
それからちょっと時間経ってから
もうちょっと証拠前言ったでしょと言ったところで
もうそれであなたは私の身分を確かめることでしょうと言って
あ そうです あ すいません
私の言葉間違って それね
それで私の登録のカードをね
それで見せたんですけど
ああ もう もう一人 あの
こちら学校に行ってる人のね
まあ学校学費をね もう本人がもうバイトありますから
もう今日払わなくちゃいけないんだと
だから銀行 3時までだから
いいえ 私が払いますよと言って
銀行に行って 全部学校から来た資料全部あるでしょう
名前も書いて そしたらまあこれはご本人様
ご本人様ではなくて 私は別の人やと
それだったらお金は入れることはできませんと
あのね 今日はこのお金を学校に送らなくちゃいけないんだと
それでこの学生さんを今連れてきなさいと言うんですか？と
あいつもどこか行って
学校かバイトかどこか分からないんだと
だからいえ 振り込め詐欺事件もありますから
これわかるでしょうに
これ学校の名前印刷しているんだからね
これ振り込め詐欺になりませんよ
で こいつもどうしてもあれやこれや言ってもお金を受け取らない
冗談じゃねえだろ 今お金出さなきゃ
もう明日にはもう学校で取り消されますよ
こちらとしてはもうやっぱりご本人様でなければ
って あのね もしこの学生が小学生だったら
幼稚園児だったら あなたその幼稚園児にお金振り込みなさいって言えますかと
今お金送ってくださいと
今あなたの話はどうでもいいんだと
それだけ それでもうまたマネージャーが出てきて
あちらへ来て あちらへ
そこで裏で書くんですね
この親戚で関係は関係は親戚やと
親戚でなくてもいいじゃないですか
で まあそういうわけでもう書いて
それはそれで書いておくだけで
誰も見ようとも何でもないんですよ
結局 だからこの振り込め詐欺事件をなくそうと思って
振り込め詐欺事件はそのまま置いておいて
余計なところでガードするんですよ
まあそこまでバカがこの宇宙にいるのかよと
わからないけど だって銀行も倒産する国だからね
だからそんなものに乗っちゃうと生きていられません
私は乗りません  最後一つ伺いたいんですけども
長老は怒らないことという本を書かれていて
私もすごく参加させていただいてるんですが
時と場合によってはたまに怒ってもいいんでしょうか
怒ったら負けますよ  負け
負けます ああいう風に私は攻撃するんだけど
怒ってない私にとってはものすごい漫才なんです
私は自分で一人で漫才やってます
むちゃくちゃにさせちゃって
ものすごい楽しいんです
だってあのみんなロボットのように動くでしょ？だからプログラミングにないデータ入れるでしょ
入れるとこの動きが止まったりして
楽しくてしょうがない
同時に真面目に頑張ってる人だったらすごい褒めてあげたりする
そういうことをしながら結構仲良くもなります
だからあれよりはもうものすごいマンモス銀行でしょ
新宿のブランチが なんか自分の家に行くような感じなんです
こともない で もう書いてくれるところまで来るんです
そうすると書いてあげましょうかとか
だからまあやっぱり怒ったらね
規則破る場合でも怒ったらもうできないんです
はい  はいはい  先ほど先ほどのお話を
あの長老の話なんかを聞くと
私なんか気が小さいので
そんなことがあると  結構
あの まあ怒るということで
そういう銀行とか まあ世の中のことで
そういうトラブルがあると
とても気が小さいのでずっと悩んでしまうんですけれども
今日のお話を聞くと あまりその何事も結果が悪い
悪い結果が出ても あんまり悩まずに
そんな大したことはないよというふうに聞こえるんですけど
よろしいでしょうか あまり気にせずに
もうその間違いがあるかもわからないけれども
そんなに完璧には生きれないから
もう気にせずに あの まあそのところで終わらせて
次に行きなさいっていうふうに聞こえるんですけども
よろしいでしょうか あの
あんまり意味がないよ
全てっていう風に怒っても
私だったらもう銀行でそういうふうに怒ってしまったら
次の日もその夜も眠れずにずっと考えるんですけど
でも楽しんでいらっしゃるということは
あんまりそんなに人も気にせずに生きていった方が楽っていうことでしょうか
まあ私はただ怒ってもないし
あの女の子がね ちゃんと仕事終わってから
私 すごくありがとうございますとか何とか
もうお互い仲良くわかりましたからね
じゃあねという感じで
で だからまあまあ怒らない
私も怒らないんだから
私すごいニコニコと冗談で理屈出すんですね
なんか弁護士が質問だということはですねと
ええ感じでね 言っちゃうと向こうはもう
諦める場合 まあ別にどうったことないものの場合は諦めますけど
やっぱり ああいう その日でその人にそのお金
その口座に入れておかなくちゃいけないというふうに締め切りとか何とかあると諦めるわけにいかんでしょうに
結構どうでもいいことを自分で怒ってることが多いわけですよね
あんまりどうでもいいことの方が多い
思って生きればいいですね
そうそう その通り まあどうでもいいことでね
あってもなくても大したことはないんだとね
でもこれはという時だけ力を
それはしっかり力を出さないと
わかりました ありがとうございました
そろそろ皆さんよろしいでしょうか
はい マイク  奥の方に今手挙げている方にマイクを回してください
最後の質問ということでお願いします
さっきの自由意志なんかの質問ですけど
さっきのお話を聞いていて
自由意志があるかないかっていうふうに考える時って
例えば今日僕ここにいるんですけど
ここに僕いるっていうのは
僕の中だと貪瞋痴があるから
貪瞋痴が判断してここに来たってことは
ここに来ることは悪いことだっていうようなしてしまうんですけど
でもそのようではやっぱりないわけですよね
貪瞋痴で普段悪いことばっかりしているんだけど
何かのきっかけがあってここまでやってきた
で ここにいる僕がここに来るまでに
多分何回かこうこういう風に判断して
こういう風に判断してっていうのは何回かあったと思うんですよ
で 自由意志っていう時って
その何回かあった時の最初のこっちに来る分岐のところが自由だったのか
自由じゃなかったのかっていうところ
やっぱりポイントになるのかなっていう気がしたんですけど
でもそれって あの えっと
なんか前のあの講演会みたいなので
無限にこう考えていくっていう人間にはできないみたいな話があったと思うんですけど
なんかニワトリの卵みたいなことを僕は追ってるような気がしていて
で えっと そのなんか俯瞰的に見ると自由意志みたいなのはあるとも言えるけど
一個一個のその ここにいる条件というか
ここにいる前の判断は
こういう条件があって
こういう条件があってっていうところに関しては
やっぱり自由意志がないから
両方とも成り立ってると見えるとか
そういうふうな理解でいいのかなと思ったんですけど
見る立場によりますね
例えば車で千葉県までドライブしようとする
なんか自由なように感じるでしょ
しかし もの厳しい規則の中でやってるでしょ
道は決まってるし ナビは案内するし
高速道路に入るとその料金払うか払わないかわかりませんだけど
その決まり守らなくちゃいけないし
スピードのあれやこれやとかね
それはすべて決まってるパターン全部守ったから
もう千葉まで行けたということになっちゃうんですね
だから見る立場からね
自分だけで見ると 私が今日は千葉に行きたかった
それは私の気持ち これ成功しましたと
誰にも関係ないんだぞと言われますよ
逆に自分を捨てて ある
ある物体が千葉まで移動しましたという風になってくると
全然自由が利いてないんですね
自分という物体と車という物体が千葉という場所に移動しましたでしょ
その立場から見ると自由が機能してないんです
全部決まってる法則を守っただけ
因果法則 だからどこから見るのかっていうことなんですね
うん それから自由意志のもう一つ覚えてほしいポイントがありますね
これは大事なところ 私は貪瞋痴で判断すると言ったでしょ
だいたい貪瞋痴の判断というのは間違いには決まってますね
もし貪瞋痴の自我が 自我錯覚がする判断が全て完璧に間違いであるならば
私たちは今ここにいるはずがないんです
この地球上に存在するはずがないんです
存在は成り立たないんです
なぜ一回の失敗で命がなくなりますからね
もし逆に 自分の予断ですね
予断の判断が全て正しければ
人間には微塵も苦しみがあるはずがないんです
世界に微塵も問題があるはずがないんです
皆完璧であるはずなんですね
そういうわけだから しかし
世の中を見ると 間違ったり
いいことをしたり 悪いことをしたり
人を助けたり 人を殺したりとかね
ごちゃごちゃの混沌の世界で私は生きているのは
一人の人生にとっても
あれはうまくいったんだけど
これはうまくいかなかったとかね
で 奥さんと朝喋った時はうまく話が弾きましたけど
後から電話したらケンカになったとかね
そういう人生なんですね
はい ということは この先入観の判断の状況なんですね
完全悪い判断するわけではないんです
だからといって正解 完全正解判断するわけでもないんです
その都度その都度当たり外れなんです
判断するとき 当たったらうまくいっちゃいます
外れたらもうダメになるというね
そこで真里亜で外れが多い人間がいたりしてね
当たりの方も結構ある人がいたりして
そこで俗世間で あの人は成功者
この人は失敗者とか言ったりもしますね
だから先入にはよ 余談
余談の判断ですね だから余談の判断は完全正しいわけでも
完全間違いとも言えるものじゃないんです
例えば貪瞋痴があったりしても正しい判断する場合はあります
例えば貪瞋痴で悩んでと苦しんで
あるいはもう頭がおかしくなってて訳も分からない
どうしようかと そうすると
あんた頭がもうごちゃごちゃですから
ちょっとしっかりしましょう
しなさいよという判断する
それで じゃあゴートミーの勉強会でも行ってみたらどうかなと自分で判断するんですね
だからそんな感じでいろんな判断するんです
だから貪瞋痴がやったことで
人が悩んだり苦しんだりするになってくると
同じ貪瞋痴がこうしたら
こういうことをしたら治りますよという場合もあります
それまた当てにならない
時々もうむしゃくしゃしているんだから
人は誰でもいいんだから殺せという判断もするでしょ
この予感 予断が それでむしゃくしゃしている人が仏教勉強会にする場合も来る場合もあります
そこでどんな判断が正しいかということを結果で決めなくちゃいけない
むしゃくしゃしてたんだから
誰でもいいんだから殺したかったと
大成功ですね その行為だけは
しかし それからは何なのかと
だからまあそこでこちらに来て仏教を勉強して
しっかり真剣に人間になってやろうと言ったっても
なかなかそうなられるケースもないんだけど
だからそんなに大成功ではないんだけど
結果はいいはずなんですね
だから一つの判断は成功しましたけど
後から最悪 じゃあ仏教を学ぼうとしたところで
ろくに聞いてもないし
あれやこれやとかね よく半分もわかってないとかね
いろいろごちゃごちゃですけど
だから大成功とは言えませんだけど
結果どうですかと でも自分が気持ち落ち着いて
なんとかもうまあまあで頑張れる状態になりましたから
まあそれで結果論でいいことになるでしょ
[ no sound ]